Nicole starts off this hour in New York
City
Merry Christmas Nicole how are you merry
Christmas to you it's such an honor to
be on the call well thank you how can I
help
so my question today is kind of more of
a moral question I went to school
between fall 2007 and spring 2010 and at
the time I'm an only child so my parents
took out a massive Parent PLUS loan for
me probably to the tune of I'd say
probably 120,000 in total student loans
combination of what they took out and
about 25km my name is Lourdes you today
I'm 29 years old working through the
baby steps just got to baby step 3 and
I'm kind of realizing the massive we
must still be on their shoulders because
of this loan and I'm trying to figure
out how to help them whether I should
help them you know I paid off the
portion that was in my name in my debt
but just the fact that they have so much
on their shoulders because of my
education is just waiting heavily and
I'm just trying to figure out how
exactly I can help them with this Joe
how much debt is left in the Parent PLUS
loan probably according to what I've
calculated and the limited information I
have about 135,000 okay and what is your
income 88,000 and what is there's
probably 110 a year between both parents
okay well I don't think you have a moral
obligation in the sense that you didn't
promise to pay it
it wasn't your deal with your parents
that you were going to pay it have they
overextended themselves to help you yes
and would it be nice for you to help in
return and help them clean this mess up
yes and but but do you have a moral
obligation no because I don't think
there was a promise made that's been
broken you know yeah you know it's but
but isn't a nice thing and you've got a
wonderful heart and I appreciate that
probably if I'm in your shoes would
finish your emergency fund maybe step
three and I assume you're gonna see them
during the holidays yep well why don't
you just sit down away from the rest of
the family just the three of you you
know and just talk a little bit about it
and just go look here's what I've been
doing I paid off this much debt in this
period of time
I've almost got my emergency fund
finished I'm following this weird Dave
Ramsey guy and I'm doing this stuff and
I'm really starting to feel kind of
confident going forward with the money
I'm making good money and I look over
here and truthfully I feel bad about
this pick a big pile of debt you guys
have so I mean let's talk about it and
then let them tell you what they're
thinking and how they feel and and it
could end up that you know if
everything's kind of healthy in the
conversation and communication and
nobody's feeling weird or something if
that maybe both of you agree to jump on
it with gazelle intensity and maybe they
maybe they learned something and between
the two you kind of end up splitting it
but I don't want you to take on half of
it and then limp along with the other
half I'd want you to take on half if
everybody was going to get really
excited and between all of us we have an
over $200,000 worth of income and an 88
thousand dollar loan and so let's have a
plan for knocking that out in like 18
months you know together right you know
I love that I just I know unfortunately
you know as generous and as loving as my
parents are I've also witnessed you know
just I guess a lot of mistakes me
there's a lot of things going on in the
house that I think you're making the
situation worse yeah well maybe this is
a chance to heal it I would love that
I mean I will probably be playing back
this call so yeah I mean sometimes you
but sometimes you have if you can
develop a common enemy
you can both sacrifice some of the
things that you know and fix some of the
stuff necessary that needs to be fixed
to keep the enemy out you know and if
all of you gang up on this I'm okay with
you participating I'm not okay were you
just going
they're lame-o so I'm going to take the
whole thing no that's probably not
healthy and it's also kind of not
healthy for you to just start paying on
it but they don't pay much on it and it
just this lingers for five or six years
then you know alright and I know they're
not going to be able they're not going
to commit to paying more than the
minimum payments I mean honestly that's
probably how it got to 135 K after being
graduated but they could good I could
and and mom and dad if you guys would
get home like and let's get excited and
let's all do this together and you guys
get on a budget and I'll show you what
I've been doing and and I'm not telling
you how to do everything but if you all
do all that I'll jump on here and
between the two of us I think we can
knock this thing out real fast if you'll
do that if you'll do that I'll help if
you'll do that I'll help but if you
don't do that I don't I'm gonna have
trouble helping yeah well it's in there
I've seen your books laying around the
house I don't know why well it doesn't
you know maybe now you've got a common
enemy and if you can you know come on
you know come on do it together we'll do
it together you know come on we'll do it
together and and I think there's
something powerful there that might
cause them to believe enough to
sacrifice believe enough to get
organized believe enough to get on a
written plan because you gotta believe
to go do it
this stuff's hard as you've already
discovered so I appreciate your heart
appreciate that you feel responsible to
help not morally but just responsible
that's nice
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you